die Nerven liegen blank bei denen die
Angst haben vor der nächsten Gasrechnung
es sind rund 500% mehr
hat mich natürlich schockiert und
trotzdem ich kann nichts tun und bei
denen die Verantwortung tragen für Preis
und Sicherheit und das hören wir von der
Opposition die
gasformel Stadion
gerade die gasumlage legt offen wie SPD
Grüne und FDP gegeneinander regieren wie
Überlastung Missgunst und eine
männerfede Lösungen blockieren
am Mittwoch verkündet der
Wirtschaftsminister der versorgungsriese
uniper werde verstaatlicht damit
entfällt eigentlich der Hauptgrund für
das rettungsinstrument gasumlage
trotzdem müsse die erstmal kommen sagt
Habeck als Soforthilfe die gasumlage
haben wir ja nichts aus Willkür oder Jux
und Tollerei erhoben sondern um die
Unternehmen im Markt stabil zu halten
und sollte die gasumlage nicht mehr
erhoben werden können muss sofort eine
Alternative aufgebaut werden
harbex Rivale im Kabinett ist jetzt
wieder Christian Lindner der wischt
zunächst die rechtlichen Bedenken Weg
die auch Harbeck bei der gasumlage hat
seine Juristen hätten das schon geprüft
heute dann erklärt er die Umlage
trotzdem für falsch und nutzt die Chance
den lange populäreren Habeck zu typieren
die gasumlage Macht die Gaspreise teurer
sie sind ohnehin schon extrem hoch was
wir jetzt brauchen ist die Gaspreis
Bremse ähnlich wie die strompreisbremse
die schon besprochen ist die die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher und die
Betriebe von den enormen
Belastungsspitzen entlastet und ich
werde darauf achten dass wir eine
Finanzierung finden die die
Schuldenbremse im Grund im Grundgesetz
achtet und für den Bundeshaushalt auch
erreicht
Olaf Scholz betont dass es ja habe war
der die Umlage ausgearbeitet habe noch
aber hält er daran fest seine SPD
allerdings will schon markieren Sie sein
es ja nicht gewesen der Parteichef sagt
in der SPD gab es von Anfang an bedenken
was das Instrument der gasumlage angeht
rot-gelb-grünes gegeneinander der
Finanzminister der Wirtschaftsminister
sind bei der Umlage uneins der
SPD-Vorsitzende sagt ja vielleicht
brauchen wir sie doch nicht also es ist
halt viel Verunsicherung da das wäre in
normalen Zeiten vielleicht unterhaltsam
diese Schauspiel aber wir haben Krise
die Probleme die man die man jetzt
erwarten konnte bei der gasumlage das
war ja absehbar es wäre dringend
notwendig dass die ampelregierung
klarere bessere Pläne liefert das ist
ein ziemliches Chaos gestern tagte zum
ersten Mal eine Kommission die
Vorschläge erarbeiten soll wie man den
Gaspreis Deckeln könnte die Umlage macht
ihn teurer die Mehrwertsteuersenkung
wieder günstiger und dann vielleicht der
Deckel
Professor Jens südekum berät das
Wirtschaftsministerium und kritisiert
das bisherige Flickwerk das ist für die
Verbraucher natürlich sehr sehr
verwirrend wenn da verschiedenste
Instrumente parallel existieren einige
machen den Gaspreis teurer andere Deckel
die dann wieder ich glaube man sollte
dann mal etwas aus einem Guss machen und
eben wirklich auch den Menschen sagen
was kostet Gas denn jetzt um den
Unternehmen und dann nicht sozusagen
viele parallele Instrumente aufbauen
harbex Dilemma eigentlich will auch er
die verunglückte gasumlage so schnell
wie möglich loswerden gleichzeitig
vieles jetzt auf ihn zurück wenn nach
dem abschaffen die Gasversorger ins
Wanken gerieten auch in der eigenen
Partei ist die Umlage maximal unpopulär
die Grüne Jugend kritisiert den eigenen
Minister
als Grüne Jugend sind wir schon länger
der Meinung dass die gasumlage für die
jetzige Situation das falsche instrument
ist in einer Situation wo so viele
Menschen so starke Belastung gerade
erleben und die entlastungspakete
gelinde gesagt mittelmäßig sind weitere
Belastungen zu beschließen das haben wir
schon immer für falsch gehalten
weder FDP noch SPD noch Grüne wollen die
gasumlage wegen Überlastung Missgunst
und einer männerfehde in der Ampel
könnte sie in sechs Tagen trotzdem
kommen
und bei mir im Studio begrüße ich den
spd-kurvorsitzenden schönen guten Abend
Lars Klingbeil Herr Klingbeil das war
schon auffällig in dieser Woche wie nach
und nach alle von der gasumlage in der
vorgeschlagenen Form abgerückt sind die
SPD mittlerweile auch auch Herr Lindner
hat sich heute noch einmal deutlich
distanziert man könnte praktisch sagen
in der Ampel ist eigentlich niemand mehr
übrig der die gasumlage so haben will
warum lassen Sie sie nicht gleich ganz
fallen die entscheidenden Gespräche
müssen jetzt schnell geführt werden in
der Regierung trotzdem finde ich es
richtig dass man Skepsis so wie ich das
getan habe dass man sie öffentlich macht
wir haben jetzt entschieden dass wir in
anderen Weg bei uniper gehen um die
gasversorgungsinfrastruktur zu sichern
durch die Verstaatlichung aber ich sage
ganz klar dass für mich damit politisch
diese gasumlage auf wackligen Füßen
steht jetzt gibt es auch also es gibt
rechtliche Bedenken es gibt
wirtschaftliche bedenken dass alles muss
jetzt in der Regierung schnell geklärt
werden und wenn man einen Weg findet auf
diese gasumlage zu verzichten dann wäre
das ein richtiges Signal an Verbraucher
aber auch in die Unternehmen in
Deutschland die hoch belastet sind wenn
wir uns jetzt anschauen wie diese Karte
verlaufen ist da hat haben sich Herr
Habeck und Herr Lindner gegenseitig die
Verantwortung zugeschoben und sich auch
Vorwürfe um die Ohren gehauen was sagt
das eigentlich über den aktuellen
Zustand der Ampel aus ich glaube Politik
muss die Kraft haben Fehler zu
korrigieren das ruckelt auch mal das ist
in einer Zeit in der die Regierung
gerade ja in einer
Wahnsinnsgeschwindigkeit wirklich
tiefgreifende Entscheidungen gemeinsam
treffen muss kann das mal passieren wenn
es harte Fahrt war dann haben wir immer
wirklich auch weitreichende wichtige
Entscheidung getroffen zum Beispiel in
drei koalitionsausschüssen mit drei
entlastungspaketen also ich habe kein
Zweifel dran dass wir in der nächsten
Woche wirklich dann auch eine finale
Entscheidung zu gasumlage bekommen
werden aber klar ist eben wir müssen
auch die Kraft haben das offen zu
diskutieren und uns notfalls auch zu
korrigieren nächste Woche ist ja schon
mal eine klare zeitliche Eingrenzung
aktuell gibt es relativ viele Menschen
die sich drüberbeugen um noch mal zu
prüfen das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
prüft das Finanzministerium prüft das
Innenministerium prüft und die
SPD-Fraktion prüft auch noch einmal
gesondert wessen Eindruck und wessen
Entscheidung ist denn dann am Ende
ausschlaggebend für die
gemeinsame Minister der muss am Ende den
Vorschlag auch machen wie es mit der
gasumlage weitergeht ich habe das selbst
vor ein paar Wochen ja mal kritisiert
weil es da dann nach außer dass ein Weg
gewählt wird bei dem Unternehmen die
Milliarden Gewinne machen noch
Milliarden von den Verbrauchern
obendrauf bekommen da Robert habe ich
gesagt diesen Weg korrigiere ich ich
werde neun Vorschlag machen auf den
warten wir jetzt erst der zuständige
Minister und er wird sicherlich bald
präsentieren wie es mit der gasumlage
denn final aussieht und seine
Parteivorsitzende Ricarda lang hat heute
schon gesagt vor dem Aus der gasumlage
solle bitte Christian Lindner als
Bundesfinanzminister einmal die
Finanzierung einer Alternative zur
gasumlage vorlegen teilen Sie diese
Meinung also wir müssen jetzt alles tun
darum geht es mir ich mag diesen kleinen
Streit gar nicht der da manchmal
entspricht wir müssen jetzt ganz klar
zeigen als Bundesregierung als Parteien
die diese Regierung tragen wir tun alles
um Arbeitsplätze Unternehmen in diesem
Land zu retten wir tun alles um
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher zu
schützen vor schwierigen Wochen Monaten
die vor uns liegen da darf es kein
Zweifel geben das im Vordergrund steht
deswegen brauchen wir beispielsweise
jetzt auch eine schnelle Entscheidung
der gaskommission ich will dass wir den
Gaspreis Bremsen dass wir zu bezahlbaren
Gaspreisen zurückkommen und diese Dinge
müssen jetzt alle entschieden werden die
Kosten aber es kostet eben auch wenn wir
jetzt nichts tun und deswegen ist klar
die Regierung muss jetzt sehr schnell
handeln in all den Bereichen nicht
gerade angesprochen
müssen also erstmal haben wir im letzten
Koalitionsausschuss ja noch klar gemacht
die 65 Milliarden die sind finanziert
durch den Bundeshaushalt bei der
strompreisbremse kriegen wir die sogar
aus dem EEG finanziert wir suchen jetzt
nach Wegen auch den Gaspreis abzusenken
aber für mich steht im Vordergrund dass
es passiert und daran darf es kein
Zweifel geben der Gaspreis ist zu hoch
für die Unternehmen für die Verbraucher
und der muss jetzt runter vieles in
dieser Debatte dreht sich um die Kosten
für die Privathaushalte aber es gibt
natürlich auch die Wirtschaft Robert
Habeck hat heute Herr Lindner gedrängt
die Ausweitung des Rettungsschirms auf
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen
anzugehen wann muss denn das bereits
angekündigte entlast Paket das nächste
für den Mittelstand aus Sicht der SPD
kommen besser Morgen als übermorgen die
Unternehmen leiden jetzt die haben jetzt
die hohen Gaspreise ich habe genug
Unternehmen auch in meinem Wahlkreis die
mit schwarz auf weiß auf den Tisch legen
wie bei Ihnen die Gaspreise nach oben
schießen wie hoch die Belastung sind und
ich erwarte dass der Wirtschaftsminister
jetzt in aller Klarheit auch in den
nächsten Tagen ankündigt wie die
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen aussehen und
vielleicht hilft es wenn die beiden ein
bisschen weniger öffentlich diskutieren
sondern sich an Tisch sitzen und zu
Lösung kommen ganz klar den
Wirtschaftsminister nicht an den
Finanzminister das ist eine Regierung
das kann man gar nicht trennen nach
irgendwelchen Parteifarben das kann man
nicht nach Ministerien trennen am Ende
gibt es eine gemeinsame Verantwortung
die wir tragen und klar ist es muss an
jeder Stelle deutlich werden diese
Regierung erfüllt jetzt das mit Leben
auch was Olaf Scholz angekündigt hat you
never walk alone das wird jeden Tag
jetzt gelebt und es geht darum
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher zu
schützen und das muss jetzt passieren
sie sagen es wird gelebt ich höre
trotzdem noch einen Appell an mehr
Gemeinsamkeit heraus herzlichen Dank für
dieses Gespräch